[Music]
thank you
before we get going I'd like to give you
a quick reminder to subscribe to our
YouTube channel you will not regret
subscribing to our YouTube channel to do
that you click the Subscribe button at
the bottom of your screen and also tap
the Bell icon to make sure you get
reminders and never ever miss an episode
now Vladimir Putin is selling his war in
Russia as a war just not against the
Ukraine but against a spiritually
decadent and bankrupt West a western
world that we all live in that is
obsessed with
gender debates the denial of biological
reality
and drag queens and lgbtq issues and so
on
Lionel Shriver our brilliant columnist
has a column in this week where she says
the problem here is that Vladimir Putin
has a point
uh Lionel joins me now alongside the
writer Rob Henderson
Lionel why does Vladimir Putin have a
point
well if nothing else
things that are in in the big picture
small and um so it's distracting us from
solving bigger problems uh
but I would also maintain that something
like the
uh transgender movement is
significant it doesn't pertain to that
many people although it does affect the
way our children are being educated
but its significance really has to do
with the
denial of reality and when you start
denying reality uh well there's no
natural limit is there
um
I mean if I were this if I were the
former Soviets
um I couldn't come up with anything
better than the package of obsessions
that we've come up with
and in the column I mean I which I have
to admit is something of a rant
um it's it's it's a set of
um
of of
positions and attitudes that really come
up come down to uh a self-dislike a kind
of burgeoning fifth column within the
West that is
destroying itself and you know one of
honestly one of those elements is the
obsession with Net Zero which uh is
looking as if it's going to be quite a
minority
um
uh Obsession
especially when it comes down to
actually doing something about it rather
than talking talk is cheap
but if only the West really gets on
board even assuming that all the the
climate change
uh activists are are correct
you know all the sacrifice is not going
to make any difference and and again you
know
if the Russians were to come up with uh
an ideology that would be perfectly
designed to
impede and even defeat the West this is
perfect you know we we're busy trying to
convert to a technology we don't even
have yet really and to uh you know make
everything electric before we actually
have the means of generating that
electricity it's completely insensible
and 84 percent of the uh of the world's
energy is still
based on fossil fuels and we're acting
as if you know virtually tomorrow we can
live without them
um
just across the board you know uh
Freddie you sent me a really interesting
clip of uh uh
Soviet dissident
who defected and
talking about how the KGB primarily uh
tries just had been trying to subvert
the U.S not through spying but through
um ideological corruption
and it's almost as if that's what
they've been doing I mean
I I feel as if you know I I calling it
woke now is insufficient we're all sick
of the word anyway
um and it's just too small and Too Cute
this is something deep and terrible I
mean this whole thing of having rejected
meritocracy and and now awarding uh all
kinds of positions to people just
because of what race or sex or uh sexual
uh orientation they have I mean that's
that is a recipe for self-destruction
yes and Rob it's not just uh Russia is
it I mean a lot of other countries are
starting to see the West uh America and
its allies in this way
um China uh does to a certain extent the
bric countries do and in fact a lot of
these countries in their various
International conferences and so on talk
about a geopolitical Tipping Point
um where American hegemony is coming to
an end and we're moving into a
multilateral world
and it's obvious to them
that uh the culture wars if you like are
a sign of
um Western weakness
um and indeed that they may they may
even be trying at some level to stoke it
have you seen any any evidence of of
other countries trying to stoke the
culture wars in order to prove that the
West is in Decline
uh sure I mean there have been some
interesting pieces uh especially during
the the rise and the demonstrations of
2020 of uh China developing Bots and
hiring individuals to Post online on
social media accounts to stoke uh a
contentious debate and and to troll
people and to essentially uh sort of
cultivate hostility and animosity uh
between Americans and this is this is in
their interest to do so I mean one of
the things that Lionel pointed out in
her column uh which I which I found
fascinating uh was the the body
positivity point I mean this is
something that I this is this has been
this finding has been shown uh in in
multiple Outlets the New York Times
recently covered this but I'm still
shocked at how little attention it is
received which is that the Pentagon
recently really released a survey
showing that eight out of ten Young
Americans are ineligible to enlist in
the military primarily due to issues of
obesity physical and mental health
issues Criminal records and so on so if
80 percent of young people aren't
eligible to enlist I mean that in itself
shows a sort of significant cultural
Decline and we seem to not be so
interested in what's going on with with
young people uh if we are to go to and
enter some kind of conflict with Russia
and any other country whether to support
Ukraine or or anyone else
um it seems that we should be
uh focusing on what has happened uh to
young people and instead we'd rather
talk about body positivity and some of
the other issues that Lyle points out
well I was speaking to uh a an admiral
in the French navy recently who was
quite concerned he wasn't a sort of
right-wing lunatic by any means but he
was quite concerned about young people
in France and he talked about French
people he talked about British people
and Americans too and a lack of
willingness if it came to to actually
fight
um do you think this Taps into what
we're talking about here that Western
people have sort of given up on our own
culture on on what we are meant to
believe in
when the war in Ukraine started there
were some polls done of Americans anyway
and whether or not they would fight for
their country and the Figures were
appalling and
very few
um
and that's what we're talking about it
kind of
this package
of of
distractions as well as
uh
self-doubting attitudes
there was a reason if I can just say
there was a recent finding from Gene
twangy's new book Generations she
outlines the sort of characteristic
differences of the generations in the
U.S and one shocking finding that she
pointed out and I wrote about this in
the Free Press which is uh something
like 47 of gen z uh young adults say
that the that America's Founders are
more accurately described as villains
rather than Heroes now I know that uh
you know if you're talking to British
people maybe they have some some
interesting thoughts about that but at
least you know Young Americans thinking
that the founders of their own country
you know nearly half of Young Americans
viewing their the founders of their own
country this way I think this is
indicative of something clearly going
wrong with with youth
yeah there's it's a deep demoralization
and
you can trace it back
a couple of generations it's been going
on for a long time but rather than just
run its course it seems to be gathering
Steam and
it's deadly uh
on it on every level and I and I think
that
there's very you know there's very
little substitute to substitute for it
uh in a positive way you know all of the
passions are negative uh they're all
filled with Dread uh I don't even think
that there is a
a
a consuming
Vivid vision of a an ideal future that
is powering younger people you know the
utopianism or uh where we're all going
to be equal and there will be no more
racism and and there is no there are no
gender there's no gender roles and we're
all just ourselves I mean you can kind
of put together that picture but
basically what's
what what's in these people's head as
far as I can tell is very dark very dark
nothing but dread and also of of
in eagerness to put off adulthood
and of course fighting your for your
country that's the ultimate in adulthood
uh
the weird Embrace of of
not just of mental illness itself but uh
but an eagerness to have a diagnosis of
some sort and the competition over
effectively who's weaker uh which is
what the whole victimhood thing is about
who can be weaker who can be more
oppressed and therefore more powerless
uh
I don't think all all young people are
like this I I don't
but we don't hear from the people who
aren't like this very much
yes uh brother it's good to ask you to
what extent are we just beating up
ourselves unnecessarily because uh well
there's no doubt that Vladimir Fusion
wants to stoke up uh the culturals wants
to stake up the resentment of social
conservatives and Christians in in
Western countries uh he's not the ideal
ambassador of uh sort of the moral good
I mean it's perfectly obvious to most
Russians with a brain that hears himself
uh a corrupt and uh almost certainly
murderous figure
right well just just as sometimes good
people have bad ideas sometimes bad
people can make good points and I think
in this case in this instance uh yeah
he's he's made some astute critiques uh
often your enemies your adversaries can
be quite good at pointing out your
shortcomings and your inadequacies in
ways that friends can't or won't because
your friends have an interest in
flattering you or buttering you up or
perhaps overlooking uh some of your
flaws whereas your enemies can be very
good at pinpointing uh where you're
coming up short and in this case yeah he
has pointed out a lot of flaws that that
you know westerners themselves have been
speaking about for a long time I mean
you know wouldn't surprise me if Putin
himself was sort of reading a lot of the
conservative calming columnists and
commentators and just generally social
critics across the the social Spectrum
in order to understand what's going on
in America and in the west more
generally and and sort of harvesting the
most astute critiques
um and yeah as Lionel pointed out in
that piece there are so many things
going going wrong in the country and
primarily seems to be led by members of
the cultural and economic Elite I
claimed this term a few years ago luxury
beliefs ideas and opinions that confer
status on the upper class while often
inflicting costs on the lower classes
and there are a variety of different
examples uh some that Lionel had pointed
out body positivity was one that we had
mentioned earlier The Net Zero issue
um a lot of the the
attacks and critiques on on Merit as
well all of these things do serve to
make the people who are at or near the
apex of the social ladder look
interesting it you know makes them look
uh unconventional and gives them uh it
confers a sort of status to them among
their peers uh but ultimately when these
ideas are spread throughout Society or
when they're implemented into policy
these can have detrimental effects not
only for the people in the country but
but perhaps I mean ultimately it could
potentially destabilize the world order
if we're unable to stand up to uh
villains like Putin
also I'd add that uh
this whole miasma of beliefs
is contagious
and
if I were potent I'd actually be a
little afraid of it if there's if
there's any uh
you know
previously the Soviets were trying to
corrupt the the American culture but
American culture is now capable of
corrupting other cultures and I'm afraid
that I have lived in the UK During the
period that
the UK has become infected uh it is a
kind of
illness and
and it it spreads very rapidly and
uh
and the UK is is now sick it's sick with
it
and
it's you know it's obviously it's it's
spread throughout the anglosphere and
I'm I feel confident it is spreading
into Continental Europe uh the French
like to think that they are immune to it
but they're not it's already there it's
already in pockets it's already
fashionable in universities
there's been some interesting research
lately within the U.S on uh young people
who grow up in primarily
English-speaking households versus
immigrant households in which English is
not the dominant language and what's
interesting there is that young people
who don't speak English are actually
happier and have you know score higher
in life satisfaction and are generally
less anxious and less depressed than uh
children who are raised with English in
a household and one possible
interpretation of this is that you know
when you're relentlessly exposed to
American culture English-speaking media
and so forth this actually does
demoralize you and sort of undermine
your sense of confidence and well-being
whereas if you are not consuming so much
English-speaking content and you're sort
of in your little ethnic Enclave In
Pockets that are sort of isolated from
American culture that may actually be
better for your mental health and
well-being
but but not spectated TV I should add
I'm not sure
lastly actually I lost both of you this
question lastly
um a lot of Christians uh see this
phenomenon they see progressivism as a
sort of substitute religion a lot of
non-christians starting to regard it as
a substitute religion I wonder to what
extent are you blame uh what's happening
on the decline of Christianity in the
Western Hemisphere and the decline of
sort of uh ideas of Truth
um and so on and are we running out of
the kind of moral Capital uh that
religion gave us for so long
kind of standard I don't want to accuse
you of saying things that are cliches no
it's all right it has become a cliche
actually
um that the the whole explanation for
the uh Rage of progressivism has to do
with the fact that we don't have uh
established religion uh to nearly the
degree we used to and that there is some
kind of religious need psychologically
in people that will fasten on to
something uh in lieu of
um having a a
well-defined faith they'll they'll find
something else and there's clearly
something to that
um my frustration on that point is that
I was raised uh as a presbyterian and I
didn't fancy being Presbyterian from
about the age of eight and I don't like
to think that the only alternative to
um
being
crazed with
Progressive
uh you know excessive thoughts uh is is
necessarily another set of beliefs some
of which are a little weird and depend
on stories that are I regard as a little
dubious
um why do we have to have either an
established religion
which
you know I the of the sort that I
rejected when I was a kid
or you have to go nuts politically I
mean surely surely there's a way of
believing in something and having
principles and having some faith not
uncritical but some faith in your own
society and in your own future
why do you have to believe something
stupid
necessarily is there some genetic need
to believe fairy stories of some sort I
I I I don't think so I don't I don't
think that's the only way
well at the risk of seeming delicate I
wouldn't necessarily say fairy stories
but um I think maybe what what I was
trying to get at is relativism you know
it does seem to be uh the moral Universe
post-christianity in the west and
relativism is very susceptible to the
progressivism we're talking about that
is destructive and that does make people
very unhappy and and self-harming
right well I think there was uh there I
mean there was a a brief period of
relativism in the in the 20th century uh
as as religion was on the Wane and
relativism was a useful instrument to
undermine people's belief in religion uh
but I I actually do think that to some
extent people need to have some sort of
overarching belief it doesn't I'm not
sure if it necessarily has to be
religious or political but they need
belief in something whether it's a sort
of a Civic culture or belief in some
kind of stable Traditional Values or
some kind of confidence in in the
country and and it's uh its Customs but
um
in the absence of any sort of moral
order uh people you know sort of moral
entrepreneurs can step in and start to
tell people what they should be thinking
or what they should be feeling or what
they should be believing and so after a
prolonged period of relativism uh some
political activists stepped in and sort
of gave people a list of ideas that they
should be believing in a list of norms
that they should be adhering to and a
lot of people had no argument against it
and you know they were susceptible to it
and I think that is that that is at
least part of the story of what has
happened especially as as religion has
has declined
um
it's possible that we can step out of
this but we would need to have some kind
of story to replace it I don't think
that people can exist in a period of
total moral relativism
yeah the trouble with Rel with moral
relativism and and also with this
Progressive package
they both slide denialism
I mean that's what I was talking about
it the progressive package doesn't
really have any positive content and you
were talking Rob about
You Know Something to Believe In which
is not just believing what is bad
but also what is good and that's really
what's missing it's all dark and
therefore it's right next door to
nothing matters everything is
meaningless
um life is stupid we might as well be
dead I mean it's not it's not a big step
yeah yeah I mean I remember when I was
in school you know it wasn't that long
ago the 90s and the 2000s there was
still a general at least the school
system that I you know the public school
system in California that there was this
belief that uh that the founding fathers
were generally good that Abraham Lincoln
was good George Washington and you know
there of course we have to sort of
simplified maybe the fairy tale version
of the American founding but it was
still something that kids could
generally unite around and and believe
in and have confidence in and now today
now we're in the era of tear down all
the statues and Abraham Lincoln actually
wasn't such a good guy or he was
actually just as bad as the Confederacy
and so now even if you look at uh you
know patriotism or confidence in the
country those things are rapidly
declining and so naturally what's left
oh well there's the The Net Zero the
climate change campaign there's uh you
know maybe you can change your gender
maybe they're X Y and Z all of these
other sort of newfangled ideas that
people can latch onto and people can can
be awarded some kind of moral plotice
for it uh in a way that you know there's
there's no other way to so
well I think we'll wrap it up there uh
on that not tremendously cheerful uh
note but um it's absolutely fascinating
talking to you both uh and thank you
very much for coming on spectator TV
[Music]
thank you